I was able through my Connections In The
Biz uh I don't know what Biz actually
yeah
no no it's an accounting firm
but uh I got to watch the uh opening
because I I watched the first season of
your honor and uh I do love it and then
I got to watch the opening uh show of
the second season which was made
available to me oh is that possible they
got it for me it is yeah really yeah
yeah and it's uh terribly edited they
really rushed it together just dailies
he needs it now yeah but that opening
scene where you're and I don't want to
give anything away because I didn't come
out yet but what your character has gone
through
and uh that is that is a memorable scene
that the second season opens so you're
saying something that I can't even
comment you can't even comment I'm just
saying but I understand what you're what
I'm saying to people out there is you
need to you need to uh catch up on your
honor if you haven't and then this this
first episode I thought which is coming
out soon very soon uh was riveting and
it's the same thing where you you know
you're you start out this character
um who uh you know it is it is a little
bit evocative of stuff you've done
before where you're starting out in one
place and then we're seeing your
character get pulled like a piece of
metal to the point where it's a wire and
you're it's quivering and you think is
this gonna break is this going to break
at any moment this it's really very
descriptive way of putting it that's not
I like that you know I was a
metallurgist for a while I guess I guess
and so I'll they'll tell you Matt will
tell you all my all my uh you know
whenever I make any kind of Illusion at
all it's usually two it's like when you
take copper yes and you pound it and
then you apply uh you know some some
cold water yeah he only knows and
analogies and it acts as a conduit too
and then you can access other it's a
little like brass yeah
Inseparable yeah it's terrible yeah I
apologize uh but kids study Metallurgy
and then you can get into comedy you are
the vertebrae of my
[Laughter]
yeah it's it's fun the people at
Showtime are are just enormously
supportive and and they gave us the
tools the time to be able to create the
second season of your honor the way
um frankly I wanted to do it yeah it's
great too because I my favorite shows
are the ones where it's not always clear
who I should be rooting for because
there's uh it's it's a way that a TV has
I think improved so much since the TV
you know when we were growing up
television was good guy yeah oh the bad
guys are coming it's getting tense good
guy wins
credits uh and and I think
um obviously we've evolved to this place
where people that I understand their
motivations I I like them but I'm also
horrified by what they're doing I'm not
sure I agree with all these choices but
I understand why they're making them and
I think uh we've come a long way since
Happy Days no knock against happy days
but the old formula was nothing can ever
change Fonz is always The Fawns Richie's
always Richie and this is how it is yeah
and that's the way people find comfort
in that and there are still procedurals
that people do
find very comfortable they are presented
with a problem that our hero is going to
solve by the end of the episode and they
do
I don't particularly find that very
entertaining
um because it's so kind of black and
white yeah and and but it's the
serialized shows that go deep into it
and I think younger generation the
generation now that is coming up
graduate from college or whatever
they're far more sophisticated and they
demand more
uh in their entertainment yeah and you
cannot serve them the same old dish that
they had before they won't take it
because there's so many options to them
you have to rise to their level of
expectations and we were fed pablum in
those in those days you know it's like
that's that's this is what you have it's
Hawaii 5-0 yeah it's that driving music
and it's like oh something exciting is
going to happen and then it doesn't and
it's like oh okay well the other thing
is it was uh I mean I sound like a guy
describing the Great Depression but uh
because
um I didn't and no by no stretch of the
imagination did I had a difficult
childhood but there were three networks
and so there was very little competition
they were all pretty much making the
same stuff and the third place network
was making a fortune I mean you know
there was no such thing as losing money
because they were the only games in ABC
there's CBS there's NBC and then um it's
quite a while later that like Fox shows
up but when these that was it and so uh
you often watched things because the
reception was pretty good yeah that's
exactly oh I'm getting this channel in
it's that's pretty what are you watching
that's a Catholic mass
that's right you sure you don't want to
no it looks good though you know they're
doing the communion ceremony so let's
check it out but the things that we
would watch just because it came in and
I I take [ __ ] for this sometimes because
I'll I I go after the show CHiPs but
when I watch one of those now and and
I'm looking at all the logical flaws
did you really of course I did who were
you and what did you do that that needed
the intervention of some motorcycle cops
I uh I was a newlywed and I and they
don't give me much time to create a
character what are you talking about you
were guy on hang glider they said uh
this this newlywed Southern couple and
so I was talking like this yeah I mean
bad baby
come on baby let's let's drive fast you
know
I love I've got to see this episode oh
yeah and um Mike so here's the SK here's
the Scandal is that my the woman who
played my uh betrothed was a woman Kathy
shower I believe and I believe she was
like a a Playboy Playmate or a Penthouse
pet or something like that and boy Eric
Estrada was on her immediately of course
and it's like so I rarely saw her it was
like they were off and like Mr Estrada
we're ready in a minute
oh God bless the late 70s and early 80s
what a wonderful time oh my gosh I just
I I don't mean to imply that an impugn
her her Integrity
yes that's right uh that's hilarious no
but I often use that as an exam sample
of that's TV where there's not much
competition that's how it always felt to
me meaning what's happening this week
well there's some Jewel thieves and they
operate on the highway why would they
don't don't know and then the guys you
know rather than the FBI getting
involved because this is interstate
commerce crime
um we're going to ask these two
motorcycle Highway patrolmen to crack
this ring it's proximity
they're there and so then the next week
you know they crack that and then it
always ends with the beginning of the
show because I ranted with about this
with Bill Burr on the podcast once so I
know I'm repeating myself but it always
but I have to do this because you're
here it always starts with there's a
disco dance competition in the you know
policeman's Union ponchie gonna enter
guys I got to nah you shouldn't do it
punch hey wait a minute it's time for
the meeting there's some Jewel thieves
on the highway Ponch John get on it they
do that and then at the end of the
episode they're slapping the Cuffs I
can't can't believe you caught us hate
punch you better get going you're right
well you can't tell by the way I use my
welcome a woman and punch dancing and
everyone's like yeah
yeah freeze friend
that's Frank right and then next week
it's there's going to be a hang gliding
competition uh with a bunch of bikini
clad girls but first someone stealing
renoirs on the highway
but Bill gets mad he's like I love that
show I'm like no bill